they've come to mourn the loss of yet
another Soldier killed in the fierce
defense of bakmut hundreds of miles away
in eastern Ukraine
in Kiev Saint Michael's Monastery is in
many ways a symbol of that Ukrainian
Defiance as well
it was built in the 12th century torn
down by the Soviets in the 30s and now
rebuilt
his holy place gives sucker to the
families and the comrades of those
killed in this war that grinds on it's
easy to lose count of the sheer number
of funerals taking place every single
day
we don't know how many have died but
it's many thousands
further east on the outskirts of the
city of donipro Ukrainian Flags blue for
the sky and yellow for the wheat Fields
stretch into the distance
each one marking the final resting place
of a fallen soldier
the latest or almost all from bakmud
they've taken to prepare in the graves
in anticipation of more dead to come
it's guaranteed now
In The Bleak light families huddle
together paying their respects and
grieving
we met the mother sister and brother of
24 year old Alec litchko killed him back
mood
he has only just died
the family is from solidar in the East
they're homeless the Russians have taken
their land
so this brother and son is buried here
miles from home
they hate this wall but there is a
Steely resolve all ukrainians appear to
have
um
[Applause]
[Music]
Ukrainian desire to expunge Russian and
Soviet Traditions as well as its Army
even stretches to funeral protocol
[Music]
the trumpeter horns come from the
Western mountains of Ukraine kneeling as
a fallen pass by is a tradition also
from the west malpracticed across the
country
this the funeral of dimitro cochobilo a
national hero killed in bakmut
[Music]
thousands took to the streets of Kiev to
remember him and all who have died
well this is an exception to the rule
obviously a massive procession through
the streets of Kiev point is there are
funerals taking place all over the
country every single day there's been at
least three or four here in the last day
or so and there'll be many more in the
coming weeks for certain
as they wound their way to the maidan
square where pretty much this all
started the shouts of Glory to Ukraine
Wrangler
thank you what's it like for the country
having to deal with the number of
funerals that are taking place every day
it must be very hard it is very hard and
it's um
we honor the stress and uh we kind of
you know um just uh we do not go through
all the emotions we have but after
Victory I will will need a long time for
crying and for grieving for everyone
everyone will lost in this war
for now Ukraine is holding strong but
this nation's loss is already huge and
it's growing
this fortitude will be severely tested
as this war drags on
Stuart Ramsey Sky news Ukraine